i range you know
all the snatch dudes clearly out the
window i'm talking big [ __ ]
just you know where the money at man
don't play with my hoe and that itself
alone
man i'm talking about they clear their
pockets so fast
you know because you don't want me to
put my hand on you
because i'm gonna hurt you bad
[Music]
all right gorilla joe yeah gorilla joe
uh
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally
south central concrete vietnam
and tell me about your family you had
both your parents when you were a kid
well my mom my dad [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah no filter with [ __ ] here your dad
yeah yeah
you didn't have a good relationship with
your dad uh not at all
he was never there it was just my mom
you would think how is he
with the with the [ __ ] but he was
raised by his mom
you know you ever see your dad yeah
i don't fault him full time you fought
him four times yeah i haven't won yet
because he slapped me when i was
literally i never forgot that i told him
i [ __ ] him up when i got older
so i'm gonna take one more shot at him
and give me this time i'll just leave it
alone
well they ain't gonna give me this time
so uh you got introduced to the game at
what what point
you got started young man yeah 13
14. who showed you the ropes well how'd
you learn
i got my buddy man named moe
he said you sit in the garage and you
know laces
about the game you know
some of us we took to it some of us you
know didn't grab it
me i embraced it it's been your thing
ever since
it's been your thing ever since oh yeah
how many years you've been doing this
now
i'm 55. you're 55. so 13 to 55.
how many girls you got now 10 years 10
working no more
and your girls will bring you every dime
they make every penny
and you provide security i'm sure oh
yeah for sure
i mean if they know that they gorilla
blackpink
if they know that they my hoes they're
not gonna do nothing to them
yeah i i i assume that you
have a little you know quite a bit of
respect on this yeah
i put several demos down i don't know
what you did
they know don't [ __ ] with this hoe yeah
once they see
you in action i guess nothing much is
going to happen
so so the game has changed a lot over
the years yeah how how has it affected
you
not at all because i keep it old school
i don't adopt to the new [ __ ] i keep it
old school
keep it old school they can't [ __ ] with
you
because you're living by the rules of
the game
the people that don't that don't survive
is the ones who try to change the game
you can't change the game what what do
you make of all these new the
tennis shoe pimps the gang member pimps
that are out there
i mean they there's nothing to me i grew
up a gangster
so i you know i don't worry about them
they need to be worried about me
yeah and if one of your girls wants to
leave
my [ __ ] there's plenty more out there
see you you don't want to you you don't
want to hold them
where where they feel that
they can't leave because that's a whole
different game that'll get you in
trouble
so bye [ __ ] bye go but you're an
imposing i mean you know i'm gonna
put my gear down down but you know but
do you ever do you ever have to use
fear or intimidation or even even get
physical with the girls
not to slap three [ __ ] [ __ ]
with some good one you know you're
training her job yeah
that girl that [ __ ] got a lot
and you have kids of your own are you
married cute
you raise them you raise your kids yeah
yeah boys are girls i got three boys
two girls two girls so if one of your
girls wanted to
do this what do you say to that i can't
knock the game man
i can't knock the game and if she's a
part of it that's what she wanted to do
anyway
you know but i mean to some fathers
it'll be a disappointment or whatever
i have no feelings bro so
love is not part of it not the picture
here love don't live here jack
love don't live here
it's all about the money emily
you done prison time have you done
prison time
oh a whole lot what kind of stuff got
you in prison
no what what for murdery robbery
assault you know i don't do the petty
[ __ ]
if i'm gonna go i'm gonna go for
something you know
and you'll have sex with your girls
you'll have sex with your girls
go alone not all
what about drugs are drugs part of their
scene some of them do drive some don't
and if one of your girls gets a little
head strong just a little bit out of
line
what do you do
this one now
what what personality traits do you look
for in a girl are there certain types of
girls that are good for this
it's a missile that's all
we see i it's what what i
lay to them okay and if they don't
confirm to that
they're not they they don't want to be
in my stable
yeah yeah but there's clearly some girls
that are cut out for this kind of work
and other ones just aren't right
exactly like the one that was sitting
here
it's a work in progress you know she'd
probably be
you know kicked out sooner or later
because i think she's dealing with some
mental issues that i have time for
but the the pimp and prostitute
relationship is it based on what these
girls experienced as children with their
fathers perhaps
yeah a lot of them went through child
abuse sexual well a lot of them
but a lot of them they just see the
dollars like we do
you know and they if if they do the
right thing they know the right thing
going to be done to them
and what are you proudest of in your
life what are you proudest of
people are you right you were pimping
the year number two
and in all your years of doing this
you've been doing this for decades
what's the craziest thing you've seen
out there on the street
the craziest thing i've seen regarding
just like you know hijinks that happen
on the streets with the girls with the
tricks
well i i i've seen a lot but
if it ain't in previous jokes circle
i don't give a [ __ ] about it
what they doing i don't care
you know yeah the greatest [ __ ] i didn't
did i've seen all right i
did tell me the craziest thing you've
done i mean
you know all the snatch dudes clearly
out the window
i'm talking big [ __ ] just
you know where the money ain't man don't
play with my hoe
and that itself alone man i'm talking
about
they clear their pockets so fast you
know
because you don't want me to put my hand
on you
because i'm gonna hurt you bad
what's the most extreme you've had to
get with one of your girls the most
retrievable one of them
yeah just a slot
one slap i mean this [ __ ] right
here
this [ __ ] hurt they're like
getting slapped with bricks
and they don't want you see your job
that was you yeah they don't like that
you see how submissive she was today
kiss me on the head and [ __ ] there's
nobody kissing my
but a head pimp is a very different
style than the
regular example yeah the the the
stereotypical well-dressed
yeah you're not you're not flashy no you
don't do that i don't do that
that way no attention you know is on me
i look like a regular joe walking down
the street
but it's so much up in here
but what attracts a girl to this
arrangement that you have is because
they know they're going to be protected
yeah but it's also mind control it seems
well you know i i i have a get the gap
i know i i know what they want to hear
so they feel comfortable
i know what they need to hear did you
ever imagine yourself switching
swapping places with the girls where
you're the one that's having sex for
money and they're keeping the money
negative negative
joe is not for sale
and it's okay for you to to do that to
them but there's no way that would
it never happened
it'll never happen
what's the most important lesson you've
learned the most important lessons
i've learned is
to make sure that whole got your money
that's the most important
aob all on the [ __ ]
you ever done anything with the girls
where they're they're getting
reprimanded they're getting
disciplined by you well yeah
i got a [ __ ] nibble wall
i pulled mitch's fever hairs out
i'll pluck toenails off
i mean you take a broomstick in the ass
how much more extreme you want me to get
that's pretty extreme
that would get me to stay in line
i mean i you know but
some of them they i mean it depends on
how angry they give me
as how extreme they should gonna be
how strange they taught you gonna be
well
okay so joe here we are the night the
day after our previous
interview with a couple of your your
girls yeah
who do we have here i'm red
red and where's your name
monique so ladies
tell me what it's like to to work with
joe
it's interesting is he as mean as he
looks
sometimes meaner sometimes
i mean there's different styles to this
game right you could you could you could
have chosen a pimp that maybe was a
little more suave and debonair but you
you chose somebody who's
probably the biggest thug in the and
figure out because he's grounded
yeah he's grounded grounded it's all
natural not trying to be anything else
but
him but nobody says no to this guy look
at him
please don't try to say no
what's what's the what's the most what's
the scariest thing you've seen him do
oh just walk up on somebody and don't
say anything like
so if one of your one of your tricks
gives you a hard time starts playing
games
he just walks right up on me he doesn't
say anything just presence alone
right yeah nothing it has happened but
the scariest thing was just watching him
do nothing
but you respect him of course you're not
forced into staying with him
no you're uh you guys are you would
consider yourselves happy
for the most part yeah yes but he keeps
your money
yes and he takes care of you you see the
result yeah you guys are great
how many years you've been with joe five
maybe five years two three years
it's on the bottom but but there are
there are some pimps that you
would would steer away from yeah like
the ones that uh
that were too much jewelry yes yeah bill
earrings um like
how would you describe joe's style
classically old school classically old
school
and his his demeanor just kind of paves
the way for everything to go smoothly
right
yes strong silence yeah
there's nothing nice about gorilla joe
man
nothing remember no feelings
no filter either
what kind of interactions have you seen
with him and some of your guys
there's got to be some crazy hijinks
that go on when a guy's like
acting up and joe comes into the picture
well i've seen him like we call it
be a chameleon depending on how how
how they're acting up is how they get
treated
sometimes you just blend on it and make
them feel comfortable and then they try
to straighten up after that
because the word you know power words is
something else yeah
angel you have how many girls you have
quite a few right
yeah i'm at 10 right now i'm working on
more
and who's your bottom
me as a bottom [ __ ] that that means
what
that i'm his main girl so pretty much
pretty much i'm not retired but
i've graduated to the level where i just
and you help back you help recruit other
girls
yeah get them in line get them dressed
make sure their favorite though
our favorite though she's well she's
she's a working process right here we go
we getting it right together
and what what do you call the other
girls there's the uh wifey
wifeys yeah and you guys all get along
we do
they have to respect me no matter what
yeah they gotta get along with my circle
ain't no disruptive hoes gonna be
arguing in the stable man
i'm sorry no disruptive hoes gonna be
arguing unstable
yeah this is family you gotta be
you know yeah cool with each other and
i'm sure i'm sure
one word from joe keeps everybody in
line right
that part or he just steps into the room
and everybody knows that look man
all right you guys thank you so much for
uh coming in together thank you for
having us
and uh good luck throughout the holidays
nice happy holidays too thank you very
much
you